un clin d'oeil bien involontaire et un
panneau qui affiche la couleur à
l'entrée du village
mais pour ce changement voulu notamment
par les partisans d'alain juppé il y a
d'abord la primaire c'est
l'officialisation de la candidature à
gauche d'emmanuel macron qui donne le
ton de cette visite dans l'yonne
si cette annonce n'est pas de nature à
l'inquiéter elle agace quand même le
candidat de la droite et du centre
c'est d'abord un problème pour monsieur
hollande est pour la gauche
pour moi monsieur macro est le coauteur
de la désastreuse politique économique a
été conduite depuis 2012 le sait
aujourd'hui sans doute de se refaire une
virginité
au programme de cette visite des
rencontres avec différents acteurs de la
santé mais aussi du numérique lyonnais
est à la traîne en la matière il faut
vraiment que l'état et tous les services
de l'état pousse véritablement à ce
qu'on ait demain la fibre optique
partout dans cette exploitation alain
juppé est aussi venu rappeler
l'importance de l'agriculture
à quatre jours de la primaire le maire
de bordeaux cherche à mobiliser le plus
grand nombre de votants pour espérer
arriver en tête dimanche soir convaincus
que cet électorat là peut-être tentés
par la droite dure voire extrême enfin
face à ces élus locaux alain juppé n'a
pas retenu ses coups notamment contre
françois hollande et le gouvernement de
manuel valls
ce gouvernement ressemble à une première
puisque un gouvernement les jours pairs
le premier ministre ni une chose est de
l'armada mme ségolène royal de l'
inverse ou un autre ministre ça ne peut
pas continuer comme ça et la fois la
france sur la scène européenne et sur la
scène internationale est devenue
quasiment inaudible je pense qu'il a la
méthode et qu' il a l'expérience pour
reconstruire la république alain juppé a
repris la route de paris pour préparer
le débat de la primaire demain soir et
son dernier meeting d'avant premier tour
prévue vendredi soir à lille